a
[Música]
ah
en colombia la guerra contra las drogas
es una política de estado una lucha
perdida según el ex presidente juan
manuel santos el acuerdo de paz de 2016
prometía la sustitución voluntaria de
cultivos ilícitos de cannabis y hoja de
coca que se redujeron al inicio pero la
falta de apoyo por parte del gobierno y
el reforzamiento de viejos y nuevos
grupos ilegales que se lucran del
narcotráfico han revertido la situación
en un informe reciente de la casablanca
se alertó de un importante aumento en
los cultivos de coca en colombia en 2020
cercano al 15 por ciento respecto al año
anterior la oficina de la onu contra la
droga y el delito en colombia afirma sin
embargo que los cultivos disminuyeron
ambos informes coinciden en el aumento
de la producción de cocaína entretanto
el gobierno difunde las hectáreas de
plantación de coca erradicadas a la
espera de la controvertida vuelta de la
expresión de cultivos con glifosato
[Música]
en lo que va de 2021 las fuerzas armadas
de méxico han decomisado más de 88.000
kilos de narcóticos en su reciente
visita al país la vicepresidenta de eeuu
kamala harris expresó su preocupación
por el tráfico de fentanilo de acuerdo
con la secretaria de la defensa nacional
las autoridades han incautado más de una
tonelada de este peligroso opioides
sintético además en las aduanas
marítimas del país el decomiso de
fentanilo ha aumentado más de mil por
ciento desde octubre pasado cuando la
secretaria de marina se ha hecho cargo
de la vigilancia en estos puntos además
29 funcionarios de aduanas han sido
cesados y denunciados ante la fiscalía
por delincuencia organizada a la par de
ello cuatro sustancias que se detectó
son precursores de fentanilo han sido ya
reguladas la droga que más ha sido
decomisada en mexico en los últimos
meses es la marihuana con 50 mil kilos
seguido de la metanfetamina con 29 mil y
la cocaína con 8000 está en su mayoría
proveniente de sudamérica
[Música]
un reciente informe de la casa blanca
establece que en bolivia la producción
de coca se mantiene en niveles récord el
documento señala que en el año 2020 los
cultivos de coca rondaron las 40 mil
hectáreas mientras que la ley boliviana
sólo permite 22 mil hectáreas este mismo
informe señala que en el país existe un
potencial de producción de cocaína de
312 toneladas anuales
por otro lado informes locales indican
que la incautación de droga ha subido en
comparación al año pasado en el primer
trimestre del año 2020 la incautación
estuvo en 26 toneladas de droga mientras
que este año ha aumentado a 38 toneladas
respecto a la cooperación bolivia
mantiene el veto en contra de la ayuda
de eeuu en materia antidrogas pero si
recibe cooperación de la unión europea
que acaba de anunciar el envío de 60
millones de dólares a bolivia para los
siguientes años con la condición de que
se reduzcan las plantaciones de coca
hasta 22 mil hectáreas
[Música]